okay so now step one step two we finally
got to the bit that you've been training
for
we can finally integrate can you tell me
what integral I should write the area is
going to be what we worked out the first
bit what was the first thing negative 1
to 14 okay now form the integrand for me
what's on top
yeah the square root is on top so I'm
gonna start a big bracket here because
I've got a few things going on square
root of x plus 2 and now I can subtract
the funk function that's underneath okay
you can see I had to write it in this
form y equals I want to compare apples
and apples not apples and oranges yeah
so - and here comes the function yeah
okay quick thing you've got another
color there bless you or a highlighter
or something like that
now is a good enough time to
re-emphasize and remind you please put
this thing here please put it there
about about five out of the seven times
I've gone around to help someone on
their particular question this DX just
fallen off now I get why you forget to
write it because in some ways it seems
inconsequential and you seem to write on
every single question like 16 times so
can we just not write it anymore someone
tell me why you must write it I can
think of at least three reasons off the
tongue my head anyone yeah okay so this
is not just he for show it tells you
something about what you're doing with
this it's for example a DX not a dy or a
DX no no do you as we'll get to later on
so it means something what else like why
did we put this here in the beginning
why does it appear in the original
formula what's what is this thing what
is this thing that where what's the M
symbol stand for again it's a sum so so
what are the things that you are summing
what are you adding up we're adding up
an infinite series of particular objects
what are they do you remember I can draw
them in for you if you like here's one
here's another another
and I'm gradually making my poor red
marker purple what are we adding up tiny
little rectangles an infinite series of
them right well you guys know how to
find out the area of a rectangle don't
you how do you find out the area of a
rectangle you need two things don't you
you need a you need a height or a leg
you know that kind of thing and you also
of course need a a width a breath you
need this theme that's the DX event does
that make sense this has a purpose it's
here for a reason you cannot just leave
it off and say oh and then in the end
I'll do my thing okay all right now at
this point I think you've done most of
the hard work here some what the rules
take over okay so let's just do a little
bit of it and then we can sort of skip
forward to the end and you can crunch
through the numbers okay
can we um can we integrate all of these
sorry that's a should ask a different
way can we find the primitive of all of
these hmm can we find the premiere of
all these now where are you noting the
topic do you sort of have to stare at it
a little bit you're trying to work out
the answer is yes you can one of the
giveaways that in some ways do not just
you can but you have to is have a look
at the shape of the area that you've got
is it one of the kinds of shapes that
you've learnt about in like junior
school with like you know a formula like
a polygon or something like that the
answer is no it's not it's not a circle
which we've used in the past so you
can't even take a part of a circle so
you have to use the primi if you got no
other choices okay
all right let's see if we can work out
what this primitive is this is X plus 2
I'm gonna rewrite it another color ^ 1/2
we can use the reverse chain rule on
this thing what am I going to do first
yeah that power is going to go up and
once I've increased the power I'm then
going to divide by that power now I've
been saying this to a couple of years
you've been working on this but I still
write it like this even though I can say
that this is going to be the same as
multiplying by 2/3 I kind of like doing
it that way because I've got consistency
in my brain and it's
easier to work out if I make a mistake
later on oh it's because this number was
wrong and everything else is quite easy
to compare that's the integral
that'sthat's the primitive I should say
and you can quickly do a mental check
you can differentiate this thing and
you'll come back okay okay these guys
you can expand it if you wanted um it's
- and then you're gonna have another -
in there
I think that's sufficiently easy that
you can do that at the moment now so if
I subtract the first one what happens to
the X on five term the same thing that
happened before right so powers going to
go up and then divide by the power okay
we have a minus sign this is the easiest
of the lot the power goes up there is
and then and you divide by that power
which I have already done you didn't
notice okay
hey go I'm finished there's the definite
interval okay
what's left what do I do with this
object yeah I'm gonna have to do some
evaluation so get your calculator out
this is gonna be mincemeat for your
calculator what you're going to punch in
though you should actually write
longhand it's tempting to go straight
from here to a calculator line you tell
me get into the position of the person
who's looking at your paper you tell me
why it's important to actually have a
line written down here that tells me
what you're putting into the calculator
suppose I go ahead and I put into the
calculator punch punch punch punch punch
that's a lot of symbols right and I get
an answer out I get this now those of
you who are a little head know that
that's ever so slightly off it's
actually four and a half so how much can
you tell about what I did by seeing my
answer the answer is very little okay
because the calculator has done all the
work I don't even know that you knew
what to put into the calculator for all
I know you could have put four plus
three quarters and then got this answer
which was which is nice but still wrong
okay so therefore that next line that
you're about to put which I've run out
of space for someone rebels
is crucially important I know people
don't like writing it because it takes
forever as you're about to see but it
plays such an important role in
demonstrating your understanding of what
this process means you really cannot
afford to not write it ok so here we go
equals and you know if you're in columns
you may even have to put this on two
lines but that's okay it's better to
have on two lines than not at all the
first boundary is going to be big
brackets fourteen plus two three on two
three on two
now just like the point that I'm saying
you should write this line it's tempting
to just say 14 plus 2 equals 16 and you
know what there's nothing wrong with
doing that however I've been doing this
for many years and I still do this does
it someone rather than write 16 I write
14 plus 2 does someone want to give me a
suggestion as to why that's a good idea
why do I write 14 plus 2 even though I
know that that's 16 and it's not hard to
work out that 60 yeah yeah that's right
if you get this number wrong and here
you are in the exam and you've got like
10 minutes at the end so you're checking
right if you've already done that piece
of working it's much harder to find out
where did it go wrong I don't know the
workings not there anymore
okay the working is not just for the
marker the working is for you okay so I
can see everywhere the 14 appears it's
because it's the boundary right what
have I got over on the end here minus
six lots of that there's the upper
boundary are you happy with that what I
do in the lower boundary again add
multiply power what do I do I subtract
I'm taking the difference after all
between these two and now I'm going to
go again and I'm just gonna put in the
lower boundary so it's gonna look like
this
okay now like I point out before that
does take a long time to write and if
you want to speed that up that's fine I
have no problem with that like you could
if you really wanted to you could go to
this okay I just want to caution you
it's it's your risk that you're taking
in my view the time that I spend the
time that I save during this cost me
later on if I get the answer wrong I
actually got this answer wrong the first
time I did and I was like this number is
messy something has gone wrong where
have I done it and I just had to go back
to lines in the am i working to find out
okay
have I answered the question aha
you've been well trained look at the
question the question says find the area
there are no integrals in the question
we just chose to use an integral as our
means to solve the question this is the
answer to an integral it is not the
answer to the question so I would put
underneath here some people will just
say unit squared here
the mathematical pendant in me says this
is not unit squared because what I just
saw was an integral so I'm going to
state the area is will you ever lose
marks on not having a separate line at
the end no but if you want to do it the
right way this is the right way any
questions how's your brain